في بارقه امل طبيه جديده نجح اطباء في
مساعده مريض بالسرطان ومصاب ايضا بالايدز
على التعافي من كلا المرضين المريض خضع
لعمليه زراع نخاع عضمي في المانيا ليصبح
ثالث حاله يعلن شفاؤها من فيروس نقص
المناعه البشريه مجله
نشرت تفاصيل معالجه الرجل الذي اطلق عليه
مرض دوسلدو وهو الذي خضع لعمليه الزراعه
النخاع عظمي باستخدام خلايا جذعيه وفرتها
متبرعه تعاني طفره نادره في جين سي سي ار
5 وبهذا الاجراء الطبي اي زراعه نخاع
العظم استطاعت الطفل الرضيعه فيفا التعافي
من مرض سرطان الدم الليمفاوي الحاد او
لوكيمياء والبطل المتبرع هنا هي اختها
نازيه التي تكبرها بثمانيه اعوام والتي
اثبتت التحاليل انها الانسب لاجراء هذه
العمليه استشاري امراض الدم والاورام
وزراعه نخاع العظم في المدينه الطبيه بابو
ظبي الدكتور زين العابدين قال ان زراعه
النخاع كانت سبيل الوحيد لانقاذ حياه
عفيفه وبعد ذلك خضعت الرضيعه لعنايه طبيه
صارمه لمراقبه استجابه جسمها للخلايا
الجديده ومع الملاحظه تم التحقق من نجاح
عمليه الزرع بنسبه 100%
[موسيقى]
ابدا معك دكتور اولا وبارك لكم هذا
الانجاز الطبي الذي يحسب لكم حدثنا اكثر
عن عمليه زراعه نخاع عظمي لراضيعه بعمر
تسعه اشهر طبعا الطفل للاسف عانت من مرض
السرطان اللوكيميا الحامه والحاد وهو اكثر
السرطان انتشارا في الاطفال طبعا بعض
الاحيان تتطلب الموضوع عملية زراعه النخاع
وحتى العام الماضي هذه التقنيه ما كانت
موجوده دوله الامارات هي التقنيه ليست
جديده ولكن الحمد لله احنا بسبب وضع
الكوفيد 19 وصعوبه سفر الناس الخارج
ارتئينا بتقديم هذه الخدمه لدوله الامارات
الحمد لله قمنا باكثر من خمسين حاله في
اقل من سنه ونصف ولكن الطفله يعني هي اصغر
طفله في تاريخ دوله الامارات حصلت عمليه
الزراعه والحمد لله رب العالمين امورها
ممتازه وهذا الشيء الحمد لله رب العالمين
نقول حق الناس قولوا ما شاء الله
ماذا قالوا لك هل شعرت بالخوف من قبل
العمليه ما المخاوف التي كانت تراودكم
كثيرا لاستضافه هنا في الاستوديو اولا في
البدايه عندما سمعت بمرض ابنتي كنت خائفا
جدا وكنت اشعر بشيء من الصدمه انها صدمه
للعائله لان سنها الصغير كانت
عمرها ثلاثه اشهر فقط وكان هناك تشخيص
لاصابتها بمرض اللوكيميا او سرطان الدم
وفجاه انتشر هذا هذا الخبر وكان ذلك
بمصاده الصدمه
واسودت الدنيا في وجهنا لم يعد نرى شيئا
اخر كنا نشعر باننا في وضع سيء وباننا
سنخسرها وقد تعيش وقد لا تعيش وذلك بسبب
هذا النوع الشرس من السرطان الذي اصابها
انها كانت حاله غير مسبوقه بالنسبه لنا في
العائله وبالنظر الى هذا الوضع كان الوضع
صعبا جدا
لعائله لم يكن من السهل ان نفهم الوضع وان
نتقدم ولكن الحمد لله
مع
العنايه الخاصه التي تم تامينها لابنتنا
من قبل المستشفى والاطباء قمنا بتخطي كل
هذه المصاعب وهي شفيت الان وهذا جميل جدا
[موسيقى]